[موسيقى]
كل شيء بدا في في 2017 يوم انه كنت عضو في
اللجنه البرلمانيه
حيث تحملت مسؤوليه عضوه في لجنه التحقيق
في شبكات التسفير لبوءات التوتر وبما انني
كنت من النواب الذين لا يخشون كشف الحقيقه
قمت
بالاستماعات صلبه لجنه قمنا بالاستماعات
للعديد من الشهادات التي
قدمتها بعض الجمعيات والمنظمات وبعض
النقابات الامنيه وغيرها الشهادات التي
تورط فيها 80% من حركه النهضه قياده من
حركه النهضه وقمت بتجميع كل الوثائق التي
قدموها لنا في ذلك الوقت في اللجنه
وبعد مده سنتين حاولنا ان في وسط اللجنه
لجنه التحقيق ان نقدم تقرير نهائي
بعد ذلك التقرير سنقدمه للقضاء لكن اللجنه
قبلت
ولم نستطيع اكمال مهمتنا لان حركه النهضه
ارادت السيطره على رئاسه اللجنه
وارادت ان تكون الحكم والخصم وان يكون
التقرير المزورا
[موسيقى]
اذ انا تحت الرقابه والحمايه الامنيه منذ
بضع اشهر لانه
حياتي مهدده كما تم اعلامي من وزاره
الداخليه مباشره
هي وزاره الداخليه رات ان التهديدات التي
وصلتني هي تهديدات جديه
من الحمايه
من اجل
انت محميه
العديد من
انا انا اعتقد
وليس معناها جديد لكن اعتقد ان هناك
المتشددين من حركه النهضه
وراء تهديد سلامه
في هذا الملف الذي
يرونهم انهم
كشف
ورط العديد من قياداتهم مثل الحبيب اللوز
وغيره من القيادات النهضويه
فاليوم هو الملف هذايا كشف تورط قيادات
كبيره من حركه النهضه الرجل الاول والثاني
والثالث بعد درجه الغنوشي والعديد من
القيادات
نقول لهم الامن الموازي وغيره وهناك بعض
الحقائق في هذا الملف الحقائق التي
ترعب لانه هناك اختراق لامن الدوله
وارتباط هذا الملف ايضا ب اخرى
كالاختيالات
والعمليه الارهابيه التي حدثت في ذلك
الوقت
[موسيقى]